Happen, the Joe Rogan experience and
uh, got some techno Huntin as well.
But I told you about that game. That
game's very addictive, isn't it?
I'm already ready trying to get back out
there to do some more when it is over.
So itchy, right? Yeah. Yeah. No, it's
amazing man that, that game is incredible.
How long have you been bowhunting for?
I've been bow hunting since I was 16 or
17, but I've been hunting my whole life.
Wow. What switched you over
to bow hunting? I'm a high
school teammate, actually.
I used to go right behind and stuff with
a shotgun and I've been shooting the
ball since I was like 12 or
11 just three d shooting.
Are you ever bowhunter will you
can hunt with this like yeah,
like we go hunt all the time. So I,
one day before school he picked me up,
went over to my buddy's house
and got up in the stand.
When he got into the stand I couldn't
climb because I didn't know where I was
doing. I got stuck at the bottom of the
tree. I knew him a bowl on my lap. So,
but that was my first time and after
that I just kept going every now and then
in between practices and whatnot.
But now when I've got time between fight,
knowing that I'm all hunting, that's it.
Well I can tell by your Instagram, man,
I follow your Instagram, all your,
you're constantly shooting and hunting,
practicing and it's, it gets
in your blood. Lemme just
like fighting. Like I said,
we were doing technique. I do
it so much, it's muscle memory.
Like everybody thinks, oh you spent too
much time hunting, you're not training.
When I go win a fight. And I'm
like, oh that was impressive.
Like I still train two or three times a
day, but I get off from the gym and my,
I always have a bowl on my truck.
I have three bowls on one is
always on my truck. So I pull up,
popped the door is open, grab my
speaker in the targets is right there,
get like 30 to 60 shots and then go
and spend time with the family, eat,
go back to the gym, come, go to the
range and shoot indoors and it's dark.
And I'm always shooting.
I just enjoy it. Wow.
So is it like a part of
meditation for you, do you think?
100% come out to OSP fight?
That was actually the first
time I find it in Jersey.
I've been in Jersey since 2014 when the
show came out and I have to Osp Phi and
all that stuff and everybody told me,
I don't pay it.
That you was winning that fight.
You got caught.
Don't let do people get in your
head and tell you you're not there.
So actually the next day I went home,
I went and bought him a hunting license
and bought a Stan and high in Jersey for
the first time and it helped me.
I didn't think about it all from November
to February 1st I wasn't a Theresa and
every day, and I went back to
training, like fool camp, whatever.
Everything in my mind I follow,
forgot all about that OSP fight.
And that's what I told my wife. I found
my balance. You know, the thing was,
I was always in the gym and that's why
the name 25 eight came because Corey
never at the time I didn't do
anything else with train. You know,
we're trained to go to the
gym and train to go therapy,
go back to the gym and train, go home,
ruin, go to garage, hit the heavy bag,
go to mark Henry's hit pads
and go try again. So yeah.